multiverses frames itself as the
ultimate crossover fighter a sort of
dream come true scenario where anyone
can face off against anyone else it's a
bold proclamation challenging the reign
of nintendo's super smash brothers
ultimate a game that features an
unmatched all-star cast of video game
characters duking it out
many pretenders to that throne have come
and gone but surprisingly multiverses
makes a compelling claim the game which
is an open public beta has the strong
fundamentals charm and attention to
detail that those that came before
sorely lacked making it one of the best
platform fighting games ever made
[Music]
multiverses follows the basic smash bros
format up to four players meet on a
single battlefield and fight it out with
the goal of increasing damage enough to
knock their opponents out of bounds
the first team to score four knockouts
in a match or the first fighter to score
two knockouts in a 1v1
wins so far
so smash
however multiverses puts far more
emphasis on the 2v2 format quickly
establishing its own identity in the
process mechanically every fighter on
the roster has moves that negatively
affect opponents while simultaneously
having positive effects on teammates for
example whenever shaggy charges to full
power a brilliant use of the ultra
instinct shaggy meme
his partner also receives a power bump
for their next attack
one of wonder woman's special attacks
gives her a layer of special armor for
added defense and if she's close enough
to her partner she'll immediately jump
to them and give them the buff too
this idea of teamwork and synergy being
baked into the fundamentals of
multiverses is a fresh and welcome
change to the format with no two matches
ever feeling the same
victory
part of that synergy also comes through
the perk system with characters earning
permanent buffs that can be equipped
before a match and stacked between two
teammates
the wildcat brawler perk for instance
increases the damage of all grounded
melee attacks for a team by five percent
when equipped by one player with that
percentage doubled if both players equip
it
as you level up characters you could
also borrow perks from teammates before
a match begins guaranteeing stacks if
planned correctly or even train a
character to learn new perks using
in-game gold
it's an ingenious system with multitudes
of permutations especially when
borrowing and training come into the mix
and it achieves a level of strategic
planning unlike anything a platform
fighter has ever seen before
more impressively the bulk of
multiverse's modes also feature online
play
in free fall pitting up to four human
players against each other and
cross-play capabilities allowing
consoles and pc to intermingle
there have been a few stutters here and
there and the occasional now you see me
now you don't moments when a bad
connection causes an opponent to
spontaneously teleport around a map
instead of walking
but the bulk of the matches played have
been smooth sailing
accomplishing this when there's only two
players in a match is an achievement by
itself but making the network function
with four people across any number of
environments console or pc is a
herculean task and for the majority of
the time multiverses holds its own
the roster isn't quite as large as the
more established smash bros ultimate
cast but it is off to a terrific start
velma dinkley joins the aforementioned
shaggy from the scooby-doo franchise
while wonder woman reps dc comics with
batman superman and harley quinn
steven universe's steven and garnett
made the cut as did bugs bunny and taz
from looney tunes and jake the dog and
finn the human from adventure time
the 17 character roster is rounded out
by arya stark from game of thrones
iconic cat and mouse duo tom and jerry
the iron giant space jam's version of
lebron james and raindog an original
creation by developer player first games
he's the goodest of good boys the
majority of the roster will not be
available to most players when they
first log on this is a free to play game
after all and with that distinction also
comes micro transactions complete with
multiple currencies
the game does offer a rotating list of
four trial characters but the bulk of
the fighters will be locked
luckily you can earn these fighters with
in-game gold along with the premium
currency called gleamingham which is
purchased with real money however the
grind to unlock every character through
gold is longer than it should be case in
point when the trial character wrote
jason changed after the early access
period ended i had earned enough gold
through playing the game to purchase
three of the four characters from the
previous rotation with the fourth coming
only one day later
around 10 hours of gameplay for four
characters might sound fine to the most
dedicated players but that means it will
take around 40 hours to unlock the
entire roster and by that time at least
one to two more fighters will be added
this also doesn't include the cosmetics
that are only available for purchase
with gleemium including costume variants
for the cast special announcer packs
where the game's characters serve as the
match announcer and more
tackle on a battle pass with both free
and premium tiers and the monetization
is strong in multiverses
while the free to play grind here isn't
a complete turn off more generosity with
in-game gold or the option to purchase
everything with either gold or glymium
would lessen the sting that said the
game does prove that free to play can
work with fighting games positioning it
as a trendsetter for the entire genre
the announcer packs do a great job of
highlighting the voice acting and
multiverses which ranks among the best
we've ever heard
every one of the characters is brimming
with personality thanks to an all-star
cast of performers returning to
characters they help popularize
including matthew lillard as shaggy tara
strong as harley quinn and kevin conroy
as batman i am darkness i am the knight
i am batman these aren't random one-off
lines that repeat ad nauseam either
there is a level of care and detail in
some of the dialogue that goes above and
beyond what we expected characters will
address the other combatants before
during and after battles with witty
banter that simply can't be heard
anywhere else clear the way
sorry pal hearing bugs bunny called arya
stark the belle of winterfell will never
not earn a smile
just as hearing superman say let's see
how iron stacks up against steel to the
iron giant will never not sound surreal
surreal is actually a perfect word to
describe multiverses a game that brings
together iconic characters and makes
them fight
these characters are as authentic as
they come feeling as if they've been
ripped straight from their source
material thanks to excellent voice work
the team-based mechanics are truly
beyond anything else offered in a
platform fighter while the classic 1v1
format also impresses
the roster offers plenty of variety
though unlocking all of the characters
without having to dip into the real
world while it will definitely be a
chore
we don't know how much of its power
multiverses has tapped into yet the open
beta will soon give way to season one
but as it stands now the game has
smashed any and all expectations
even if multiverses doesn't unseat the
king it is more than ready to rule its
own little corner of the kingdom